are you wearing a spacex shirt so let me
ask you sure
let me ask you one one person uh who
talks about
exponential you know just
the miracle of the exponential function
in general is elon musk
so he kind of advocates
the idea of exponential thinking you
know realizing that
technological development can at least
in the short term
follow exponential improvement which
breaks apart our intuition
our ability to reason about what isn't
isn't impossible
so he's a big one it's a good leadership
kind of style of saying like
look the thing that everyone thinks is
impossible is actually possible
because exponentials but
what's your sense about um about that
kind of way to see the world
well so i think it's um it can be very
inspiring
to note when something like moore's law
is another great example where you have
this exponential pattern that holds
shockingly well
um and it enables um just better lives
to be led i think the people who took
moore's law seriously
in the 60s we're seeing that wow it's
not going to be too long before like
these giant computers that are either
batch processing or time shared
you could actually have one small enough
to put on your desk on top of your desk
and you could do things
and if they took it seriously like you
have people predicting smartphones like
a long time ago
um and it's only out of like kind of
this i don't want to say faith in
exponentials but
an understanding that that's what's
happening what's more interesting i
think is to
um really understand why exponential
growth happens
and that the mechanism behind it is when
the rate of change is proportional to
the thing in and of itself
so the reason the technology would grow
exponentially is only going to be if
the rate of progress is proportional to
the amount that you have
so that the software you write enables
you to write more software um and i
think we see this with the internet
like the advent of the internet makes it
faster to learn things which makes it
faster to uh create new things
i think this is uh oftentimes why like
investment will grow exponentially that
the more resources a company has if it
knows how to use them well
the more the more it can actually grow
so i mean you know you reference elon
musk i think
he seems to really be into vertically
integrating his companies i think a big
part of that is because you have the
sense what you want is to make sure that
the things that you develop
you have ownership of and they enable
further development of the adjacent
parts right so it's not just this
you you see a curve and you're blindly
drawing a line through it
what's much more interesting is to ask
when do you have this proportional
growth
property because then you can also
recognize when it breaks down
like in an epidemic as you approach
saturation that would break down
as you do anything that skews what that
proportionality constant is
you can make it maybe not break down as
being an exponential but it can
seriously slow what that exponential
rate is
so the opposite of a pandemic
is you want in terms of ideas you want
to minimize barriers that
prevent the spread you want to maximize
the spread of impact so like you wanted
to
to grow when you're doing technological
development is
so that you do hold up that rate holds
up
and that's all that's almost like uh
like an operational challenge of like
how you run a company how you run a
group of people
is that any one invention has a ripple
that's unstopped
and that ripple effect then has its own
ripple effects and so on and that
continues
yeah like moore's law is fascinating and
the
like on a psychological level on a human
level because
it's not exponential it's it's just a
consistent
set of like what you call like s-curves
which is like it's constantly like
breakthrough
innovations non-stop that's a good point
like it might not actually be an example
of
exponential because of something which
grows in proportion to itself but
instead it's almost like a benchmark
that was set out
that everyone's been pressured to meet
and it's like all these innovations and
micro
uh inventions along the way rather than
some consistent sit back and just let
the
lily pad grow across the lake phenomenon
and it's also there's a human
psychological level for sure
of like the four minute mile like it's
there's something about it
like saying that look there is uh
you know moore's law it's a law
so like it's uh it's certainly an
achievable
thing you know we've achieved it for the
last decade the last two decades last
three decades you just keep going
and it somehow makes it happen i mean it
makes people
i'm continuously surprised in this world
how few people
do the best work in the world
like in that particular whatever that
field is like it's very often
that like the genius i mean you couldn't
argue that community matters but
it's certain like i've been in groups of
engineers where like one person
is clearly like doing an incredible
amount of work
and just is the genius and it's
fascinating to see
basically it's kind of the steve jobs
idea is maybe the whole point
is uh to create an atmosphere
where the genius can discover themselves
like
like have the opportunity to do the best
work of their life
and yeah and that the exponential is
just milking that
it's like rippling the idea that it's
possible
and that idea that it's possible finds
the right people for the four minute
mile
the idea that it's possible finds the
right runners to run it
and then expose the number of people who
can run faster than four minutes
it's kind of interesting to i don't know
basically the positive way to see that
is
most of us are way more intelligent have
way more potential than we ever realize
i guess that's kind of depressing
but i mean like the ceiling for most of
us is much higher than we ever realized
that is true a a good book to read if
you want that sense is peak
which essentially talks about peak
performance in a lot of different ways
like you know chess
london cab drivers how many push-ups
people can do short-term memory tasks
and if there's one it's meant to be like
a concrete manifesto about deliberate
practice and such but
the one sensation you come out with is
wow no matter how good people are at
something
they can get better and like way better
than we think they could
i don't know if that's actually related
to exponential growth
but i do think it's a true phenomenon
that's interesting yeah i mean
there's certainly no law of exponential
growth in human
innovation well i don't know
well kind of there is like there's i
think it's really interesting to see
when innovations in one field allow for
innovations in another
like the advent of computing seems like
a prerequisite for the advent of chaos
theory
you have this truth about physics and
the world that
in theory could be known you could find
lorenzo's equations without computers
um but in practice it was just never
going to be analyzed
that way unless you were doing like a
bunch of simulations and that you could
computationally see these models so it's
like physics allowed for computers
computers allowed for better physics
and you know watch rinse and repeat that
self-proportionality that's exponential
so i think
i wouldn't i don't think it's too far to
say that that's a law of some kind
yeah a fundamental law of the universe
is that uh
these descendants of apes will
exponentially improve their technology
in one day take be taken over by the agi
that's some that's built in there
similarly they'll make the video game
fun whoever created this thing
you